Teen Mom star Maci Bookout is officially  a married woman the 25 year old reality  star tied the knot with her boyfriend of  three years Taylor Kinney on Saturday a  source tells ET the newlyweds exchanged  nuptials and Honey Lake Resort right  outside Tallahassee Florida  Taylor popped the question in January  with a beautiful beach proposal and it  was complete surprise  Maci shared the exciting news on  Instagram and showed off her blinding  bling writing well y'all my best friend  asked me to marry him I'm one lucky lady  I love you T the couple's shared one  year old daughter Jade and  three-month-old son maverick  Maci is already the proud mom of seven  year old Bentley from a previous  relationship who had an adorable  reaction to her engagement news Bentley  was excited but I was kind of shocked  that he was so emotional about it  and like it was like a weight lifted off  of his shoulders